now I know you gentleman had a long
flight but I have prepared a welcome
party in your honor excellent I like to
party well my job is to see to your
every need
we just uh select the woman we desire
I will take the large black one
interesting choice what did you have
some kind of a book with photos of the
women available to us if not I will also
take the sexy black one
I am not surprised at all I've been to
South America I did very well there
I think there might have been a
translation problem when I said party I
meant one that did not include sex for
pay
but one that had food and drink and
dancing that sort of thing
so no women
no we have so much to learn from each
other
birds do you guys eat
chickens
us too amazing
what is this water
I'm sorry agua in our country government
officials drink only bottled water well
I can assure you that that water is very
safe to drink
no butter please send me boy
Tom go get water
Leslie come on for your troubles
you got a chief
this is a gold-plated replica of the gun
will go Chavez used in the 1992
socialist Revolution
it is a gift this gun truly symbolizes
the blossoming piece between our two
Nations
[Applause]
we to our place to be here in your dirty
alleyway
we thank you for the container of sap
I mean bag of garbage it's funny because
Antonio said to me help me turn this car
around and
say we're sick or something or that we
lost our way of course that would be
rude to you
banana you wanted Senor finally
what
with your hands
to peel the banana
okay let's get started shall we I have a
full day of activities planned I would
like to see what the children are fed
the sweeteners
a restaurant American children are
fighting more efficiently than any other
children in the world I mean
they're like little basketballs I mean
they're huge you know workers okay
this is our thermometer
I'm trying to turn a giant dirt pit into
a community park but I need 35 000 and
the city doesn't have enough money in
its budget
I do not understand you've never had a
budget shortage
[Laughter]
Venezuela is blessed with massive oil
reserves massive I mean tremendous like
do not believe
state sells the oil and keeps all the
money and
we build whatever we want
wow well now I do not understand
I feel like my English was very clear
should I repeat Venezuela Venezuela my
country
has a lot of oil oil is food for cars
everybody doing okay back there
comfortable
well the motel we're putting you up in
is really nice
you can watch TBS
do you have tbs in Venezuela
I have everything in Venezuela
I have four satellite dishes in my
estate
we get 14 000 channels
fourteen thousand
I already know who wins project wrong
way wow I'm coming over to your house
then I see what you're getting at but no
thank you I'm still primarily interested
in a large black woman
um
the parks in Barako are far superior the
park in my hometown El parque de Este we
have a monorail and we have an aquarium
and we have the haripa amphitheater is
huge Lady Gaga played there last week
great well we don't have Lady Gaga
and I don't think she's going to come
here unless her career takes a very bad
turn but we have something more
beautiful than Lady Gaga
democracy how do you like it no how do
you like that
imagine you're holding coffee
this is outrageous where are the armed
men who come in to take the protesters
away where are they this kind of
behavior is never tolerating in baraqua
you shout like that they put you in jail
right away
no trial no no nothing journalists we
have a special jail for journalists
you're stealing right to jail you're
playing music too loud right to jail
right away you're driving too fast yeah
slow jail you're charging too high
prices for sweaters
glasses you write to jail you undercook
fish Believe It or Not jail you overcook
chicken also Jam under cocoa you make an
appointment with the dentist and you
don't show up Believe It or Not jail
right away we have the best patients in
the world because of jail
foreign